science and technology create inventions
to make things easier more convenient
and save time
innovation and invention of new
technology enable things better and help
to refine the existing ones
life without technology would be
unimaginable in modern days as
technology is everywhere around us right
from handle gadgets to reality
technologies robotics and many more
aha and vr stand first to occupy most
aspects among the vast empire of reality
technologies
with a warm welcome let's get into the
video
in the last few decades the ryzen
technology has been at its peak in
information and i.t
technologies including cloud computing
machine learning artificial intelligence
deep learning big data and many more
have occupied most aspects of our lives
and one such technology is ar and vr
as a part of today's schedule we will be
looking on what is vr and ar technology
followed by its real world applications
we then head towards the vital part of
this module which is vr versus ar and
further with its advantages and
disadvantages
at the end we have its real world
implementation in modern days
first we will be looking at what vr
technology is
vr stands for virtual reality where
users immerse themselves in a
specifically designed or simulated
environment for a specific purpose
for example medical training games etc
are explored without borders and
boundaries in 360 degrees
now let's look at the applications of vr
in education conducting academic
activities like field trips visit to
museums and historical eras is now easy
via vr to conduct virtuality with no
change in common factors
towards healthcare analysis and research
on medical terms via has made medicine
practitioners enter the next level to
avoid direct contact with harmful
substances and hazardous risk factors
real-time experience of fictional
characters or sci-fi movies animations
and motions can be experienced by all
with the use of vr in the field of
entertainment
prototyping cars help the automotive
industry to avoid multiple designs and
reduce resources to maximum via virtual
designs via vr
in terms of defense user vr helps a
brave men to experience the battlefield
environments in real time to avoid
unconditional situations in reality
towards marketing
vr promotes products where consumers can
look and feel the product in real time
via a 360 degree view which helps in
better marketing
now we can move towards ar
ar stands for augmented reality which
adds digital content in a real physical
world without any difference in overall
aspects of the content
for example consider adding a sofa in a
small space where you can place a
digital sofa in the same space to check
the look and feel without any difference
in its position placement etc
we have discussed vr and its
applications now we'll move towards the
applications of ar
unlike via air has its applicative
fields
use of ar glasses
combining virtual information with
real-world sensors with no change in
overall aspects to experience the
liveliness of objects and entities
its use in medical systems for medical
imaging helps analyze diseases with
precise information without any need of
sample traces of it
in the field of entertainment ar
augments the entertainment industry with
its eye gazing filters right from
instagram snapchat and many more
in terms of tourism er based travel apps
help explore destinations for example
google maps which provides precise
information with available nearest spots
with necessary goods and services
ar-based apps like google earth provides
search capabilities in the
three-dimensional view enhancing as an
upgrade towards education
it helps professionals visualize their
final products without developing them
or producing them with the concept of
try and use or prototyping towards
designing and modelling
so far as we have discussed vr and ar
technologies and their applications now
we'll move towards the most important
part of the module which is vr versus
air
in the comparison of vr and ar
at first vr is completely virtual with
its environment while ar uses real-world
entities like a combination of both
virtual and real elements
next
vr users are controlled by the system as
the sinking of the environment plays a
major role in real time whereas ar users
can control their presence in the real
world
vr requires compatible devices like a
headset device where ar is accessible
right from your smartphone
vr only enhances a fictional reality as
it is composed of a specifically
designed environment whereas ar enhances
both virtual and real-world environments
to move on to the advantages and
disadvantages of via and ar technology
when it comes to ar
here is more advantageous as educating
oneself with real hands-on experience
increases user knowledge the same way as
ar is everywhere today from google maps
to simulation games including knowledge
and user experience
sharing knowledge and experience without
the physical hindrances like distance a
physical element presence etc
air is an inexpensive alternative to
other media platforms where ar effects
are a combined part of most social media
apps from instagram snapchat facebook
youtube etc
to talk about vr
virtual reality in every field makes the
process easy and comfortable example
medical training eliminates the need for
a natural element
with vr users can experiment with
artificial environments eliminating
boundaries and the need for an actual
workspace
via is composed of a specifically
designed environment to avoid misuse of
users information avoid data loss and
maintain their privacy
to talk about the disadvantages first
we'll have a look at air
air is quite expensive making it less
accessible in use
it can lead to use in inappropriate
situations
causing harm as it's quite common to
access right from a smartphone
ar technology is not equipped with
security policies intruders can hack air
based devices and manipulate them
according to their
needs in terms of vr any technology in
its early stages makes it feel not easy
and the same is the case with vr
due to its rapid growth programmers find
it difficult and search for ways to
interact with virtual environments
maximum use of vr makes one addicted to
living in the virtual world instead of
the real one
vr software also takes up a lot of space
and requires a lot of computing power
compared to other devices
let's take up a question
so far we are discussing ar and vr
technology
but are ar and vr booming the industry
the answer is no
in addition to ar and vr there exist
other reality technologies like mr which
stand for mixed reality and xr so which
is known as extended reality which exist
in the modern world
for a better understanding let's look at
what mixed reality is
reality takes all these user experiences
to the next level with a combination of
holographic models and real world
scenarios
moving ahead towards xr or extended
reality is the combination of all the
led technologies including of ar vr and
mr
for example a mobile chipset both to
track your health and power graphics for
gaming
so far we have discussed ar and vr
technologies and their applications
now we'll move towards its
implementation
our company is using and hiring ar and
vr the answer is obviously yes
these technologies are a part of our
daily lives included as a part of social
media artificial intelligence companies
like microsoft the hologram environment
can be used with hololens to project to
display information
they can also help blend with the real
world or even simulate virtual objects
google uses ar in its product like
google maps google lens and many more to
simulate search results
bmw volkswagen and mercedes-benz these
automotive industries use ar featuring
fully automated cars which are
controlled via gestures and voice
control
we have now reached the end of this
module
in today's module we have discussed the
need for reality technologies including
ar and vr technology the applications
and a comparison of vr and ar
as time evolves the need for new
technologies and the use and growth
increases but we should choose the right
one that suits our needs in all aspects
leaving no harm and increasing knowledge
and productivity
i hope you enjoyed this video
questions suggestions and feedback are
welcome in the comment section below
make sure to like this video and
subscribe to our channel simply learn
and please do hit the bell icon for
instant notifications on more exciting
and informative videos
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here